[Static]
EU approves controversial Copyright Directive
including internet 'link tax' and 'upload filter'
Okay, EU
Keep laughing EU
Keep smiling EU
and see WHAT HAPPENS!!
So, you wanna ban memes?
European Union, whatever that is.
You're irrelevant!
You will never pass me!!
At least T-Series might actually pass me in subscribers.
What do you got EU?
What do you got?
This means nothing!
This is just the beginning.
'Cause you don't know
who you're messing with here.
We have one weapon,
stronger,
You just walked into a...
...tiger cage *growls*
So keep smiling.
[Laughing]
'Cause we will fight you
'Cause we will fight fire...
...with fire
This Axel Voss guy celebrated when Article 13 was passed.
Let's make a meme out of him
[Yelling] So he gets banned!
We're coming for you Alex.
"There are no accidents"
"MY BAD, FAM"
[Yelling] Ban him
How old is Axel Voss!?
55 years, huh? Well how long does trash live?
1000 years?
[Yelling] Alexa, this is so sad!
[Sad piano]
"No, it doesn't affect my baby,"
Oh really? Oh really?
"55 years later"
[Laughing] This is just bullying at this point
"You can go to prison because you murdered someone."
Alright, okay, alright
"Going to prison- You can go to prison for smoking weed. "
Now, you know what it's illegal in some states and countries
Okay, alright, okay sure
"Go into prison because you illegally downloaded a song"
I agr..-- I 100 percent agree with that, put them in with the murderers.
"Go into prison because you shared a meme"
[Clapping] Finally, thank you EU!
This is what I'm talking about!
"Crazy condom--"
God dam- [Laughing]
People really don't like this guy
[Laughing] "Alex Voss is just European Ajit Pai"
Why do all these men just want to watch the world burn?!
What did we do?
"When you upvote all of the 'The EU actually did it' memes'"
Narrator: "Young people from all over the globe are joining up to fight for the future."
Starship Trooper: "I'm doing my part."
[Miming] I'm doing my part, too!
"Using copyrighted memes,"
"making a new Pewdiepie format"
Now I can copyright you guys! YAY!
[Laughing]
"Using the drake format"
"Using the Alex Voss format so he gets banned"
Can we talk about the soy face?
There has to be a connection here
This has to be part of the conspiracy,
That relatable face when you ban old memes
"EU *bans memes*"
"r/dankmemes: Hey, let's make the EU flag a meme so they banned themselves"
"Mom Can you give me Internet?"
"To do homework"
"To do homework?"
"Yeeeeees" *High Pitch Voice*
"Actually makes memes like a *boss*"
Okay, this is-- this is epic stat. This is some top kick. I'm laughing
Haha
"When the EU is banning memes, but you've been planning on leaving"
"See I pulled a sneaky on ya"
Damn...
We underestimated U-UK.
Hey, guess I'll live!
[Laughing]
"When you watch a video about the prisoners talking about the crimes they committed to be sent to prison..."
"...and you remember that you made a meme while living in the EU"
"You know"
"I'm something of a criminal myself."
Maybe this just helps us
Maybe this adds the extra layer of "dankness" to memes that I feel like we've been losing for so long
Maybe we shouldn't be hating Alex Voss.
Maybe we should be thanking him.
The EU Alex Voss memes of course gets a...
[Yelling] 10, baby!
[Yelling] It's a 10!
[Yelling] Rest in peace!
Fuc--
[EXPLOSION]
Bye!
Bye Alex!
Finished!
You're done!
NEXT
MEME! (*Meme Review*)
If there is one thing that can save memes, we have to call...
...upon Bongo Cat.
Please Bongo Cat, we need one meme that can last for more than five days
Thanos Car was not even funny for a day
Bongo cat, we call upon thee...
[Bongo Cat plays the bongos while Super Mario World Athletic Theme plays in the background]
Bongo cat is the greatest meme that has happened since Ugandan Knuckles
[Bongo music plays]
Bongo cat is what goes to bring out of this rut that we've been in for too long, where memes are just stale
[Bongo music plays again]
Bongo cat, I mean, I've never seen anything better than this.
[Bongo music plays one more time]
It just doesn't get any better than Bongo cat.
Bongo cat, I--
I will donate a kidney to Bongo cat,
I would!
[Running in the 90’s plays]
When all hope is gone... The Bongo cat comes in and saves the day
[Moon Theme from Ducktales Gameboy game plays]
That's adorable
Kawaii desu ne!
[Singing tune]
[Mii Channel theme plays]
What song is Bongo cat gonna play next huh?
Déjà Vu?
Never Gonna Give You Up?
I can't wait to find out
Bongo cat,
you're my hero.
I aspire to be you.
[Typing Sounds]
"What did you just say about me you little--"
Damn!
No one talks trash faster than Bongo cat.
If you made a bad comment about Bongo cat...
[Playing Africa by Toto]
It's Africa
No
Bongo cat did not just play the most meme rela--
[stutters]
[Laughing]
Bongo cat did not just play the most popular meme song right now.
I am freaking out over here!
That is epic
That is so epic
[Splashing Sounds]
Oh wow, no way!
Okay, basically, that's epic.
Place your bets in the comments. How long is Bongo cat gonna make it?
Come on, we need,
we need one that lasts a week, please for the love...
...of Bongo.
I'm gonna,
I'm not even gonna rate it!
That way,
it will live--
ITS A FOUR
Oh damn it!
NEXT
MEME!
"Montclair teen's quick thinking saves her and niece from home invasion suspect"
Wha- what kind of sentence structuring is this?
"Montclair teen's quick thinking" comma,
"saves her and niece from a home invasion suspect"
Jesus Christ, you're a writer!
"He's inside mom.He's gonna--"
"He's gonna hear me"
Mom replies:
"K"
Her mom really hit her with the "K"
Her mom, a SAVAGE.
Hey look everyone, it's Thanos lettuce.
"It's a boy!"
"Okay, so..."
"Basically..."
"I'm Monky",
Yes!
This is the meme, okay?
This time can I be serious for a second?
"But okay. Basically, I'm monkey" is the meme...
ah!
How could I been so blind?
What we mean to save memes is a way for you guys to vote.
That way it's not just...
..Me reviewing memes...
Its our Meme Review.
Vote now! What's your favorite?
"Okay, basically I'm monkey"
or Bongo cat?
Y O U D E C I D E
[epic rap battles of historyy]
Finally we have the Florence...
...Hurricane that's been popping up.
Why am I laughing?
Okay, I'm not supposed to laugh on Meme Review
But there was this meme that made it to the mainstream because Florence now contain sharks.
"Hurricane Florence: life threatening storm lands in North Carolina."
Well, some people memed it, okay
They said--
it's-- I'm laughing at the memes,
not the disaster, okay?
So people made a meme about Florence before it hit which you know too soon
"Florence contains sharks,"
So people started believing that the hurricane...
...contained sharks because of this photo.
And Washington Post posted about it saying:
"A running list of viral hoaxes about hurricane Florence"
"Stop sharing shark hoaxes"
I'm not here to make a light on any natural disaster, but has anyone tried?
To give them a Fab 5 makeover?
Let's hope this meme lasts as short as possible
Everyone in North Carolina, please be safe.
But more importantly anyone sharing memes, please be safe now that meme is banned.
Leave a like if you want Bongo cat to win and leave a like if you want "Okay, basically" to win.
And that's it for me for now
Meme Review!
Youtube's...
[A$$ OUTRO]
[LIKE & SUBSCRIBE, LINKS IN DESCRIPTION] I LOVE YOU ALL HEHE